foreign
[Music]
how exciting is this when the Maynard's
streaming live to the hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of people on
Ustream right now I know okay it's the
best damn band in the land the kill Tony
Band he went to a real professional for
the I'm a millionaire
[Music]
hey this is Redneck coming to you live
from the comedy Mothership
here in Austin Texas you guys ready for
the best [__] night of your lives
tonight or what
by many to be the most important podcast
in all of Comedy kill Tony has been
giving comedians huge opportunities to
be seen by hundreds of thousands of
Comedy fans for the past decade the
direct impact that they've made on
stand-up is almost impossible to measure
at this point from episode 1 to 601 this
podcast has never stopped evolving
changing band members cities states and
even names I'm excited about this show
thank you everybody for coming to uh
episode 2 of hinchcliffe's notes and now
after all of these years Tony
Hinchcliffe and Co are preparing for
their biggest show ever which will take
place just four days from now obviously
there's kill Tony which is the
Cornerstone of like the comedy scene
because that's the new people a lot of
times that's where they get their first
set and they're doing it live and on
[__] YouTube yeah it's amazing this
Saturday June 10th will be the biggest
show in Kill Tony history that date
marks exactly 10 years since the pilot
episode debuted on the desk Squad
podcast Network under the show's former
and original name pinchcliff notes and I
was looking at Twitter and there was
some controversy
about the name because a lot of people
think you should change it to something
else what do you want it to be I'm I'm
pretty bendable at this point I always
thought that a decent name for a podcast
would be hinge Cliffs notes because it's
a it's a cool mix of like Cliff's Notes
and it doesn't roll off the tongue
though well hinge Cliff Notes I'm pretty
sure nothing with the word hinge cliff
and it's Gonna Roll Off the tongue since
2013 the show's gone through many
different phases but I think we can all
agree that changing the name to kill
Tony was the most important of them all
I seriously cannot imagine a show called
hinchcliff notes making it even half
this far nowadays kiltoni has multiple
regulars that they discovered on their
show touring the country as Headliners
an army of Die Hard fans in attendance
every single Monday and consistently
feature some of the biggest names in
comedy sitting in their guest chair
anybody that came out of it that oh was
good oh yes so many yeah I mean preacher
Lawson I think he won America's Got
Talent OR got second whatever he's doing
he's doing massive theaters yeah he's
literally I think doing better than me
we found him or very early on we're like
you're gonna be a star I mean it's
happened a lot and the guests that I've
had Tiffany haddish was a guest eight
years before anybody knew who she was
she was there goofing around and Tim
Dylan or Barry as soon as I met him I
was telling my listeners this is the
future this is a superstar this guy is
going to be one of the biggest in the
world wow and I was warning I'm always
you know very very honest when it comes
to people that I like talent manager I
mean kind of I already in a weird way am
it's a very Vince mcmahon-like job that
I have over there but you don't get to
participate the way Vince did right
besides just being the 10-year
anniversary show there's a few other
details that make this Saturday such a
big deal for kill Tony outside of a few
instances when the show's been on tour
kill Tony has almost always operated at
a very intimate rooms starting off
episode 1 on the comedy store's smallest
stage in the belly room then graduating
to the store's or and main room
eventually moving to Vulcan gas company
in Austin and then obviously now at the
mothership majority of kill Tony
episodes have taken place in front of
crowds of 400 or less until this
Saturday when they're gonna be at the
sold out Moody Theater in Austin Texas
that holds nearly 3 000 people making
this a big deal not only for the kill
Tony Squad God but also anyone who gets
pulled out of the bucket as well and
just because it's sold out doesn't mean
we won't all have the opportunity to
experience the 10-year anniversary show
live thankfully kill Tony's entire
decade celebration will be streaming on
moment house for 20 bucks a pop although
this live stream is for a special
occasion it still might be the closest
thing that most comedy fans can get to
the experience of attending any kill
Tony episode live oh my God what are we
doing outside of making a trip to Austin
especially now that they've officially
announced that kiltoni is no longer
touring there's also a good chance for
me to tell you that I can't tell you why
but I will tell the fans watching around
the world all of you that complain about
not being able to get a ticket to kill
Tony we're not doing the road that's
something to keep in mind to see the
show you have to come to Austin Texas
the rise of podcasting in general has
already changed comedy for the better
over the last few years but usually we
see these popular shows only really
helping the host or their guest which is
fine but there's something really cool
about kill Tony being different than
that normal style the guests on there
are never pushing their new specials or
trying to plug a new product and the
overarching concept has always been to
create as many new and talented
comedians as humanly possible which
they've done a great job of doing I'm
not even just saying this there's truly
not another podcast in the world that
compares to kill Tony for what it does
and what it brings value-wise to Comedy
and I can't wait to see how much crazier
bigger and better things are going to
get for them by year 20. Father's Day is
coming up fast this year and ridge is
making gift shopping easy with one of
their biggest sales of the year the
ridge wallet is the perfect gift Ridge
wallets can expand to hold up to 12
cards at once plus room for cash on the
back while still remaining Ultra super
slim I bet you can't even see that right
now but you can like that ridge's
durable material and 50 000 5 Star
reviews also means each wallet comes
with a lifetime warranty what a deal and
it's not just wallets that Ridge
specializes in they also do key cases
Rich key cases easily hold one to six
keys and prevents any annoying jingling
or clanging around if you want to be
jumping for joy this Father's Day use my
link ridge.com joke world and right now
you can save up to 40 through June 15th
that's ridge.com joke World guest spots
from last week your mom's house had on
Steph to live two bears one cave was
Burton Tom and Bert kill Tony this week
was with Doug Stanhope salvokana was on
take your shoes off with Rick Glassman
whiskey Ginger talked with riffraff
Brian Simpson was a guest on Chrissy
chaos Anthony Moore was a guest on Matt
and Shane's secret podcast and Sam Morel
was on tigerbelly and then your hair
yeah is it natural or did you
are you kidding well you could done a
monosculco and get Vlogs Oh you mean
from Turkey oh he got plugs yeah he's
got plugs damn you see those uh planes I
got plugs too I'll be in Nashville
coming up soon Birmingham Chattanooga
yeah like hordes of men going to Turkey
and getting the Fue the hair transplants
and they they all go home and the whole
plane has like it's like dudes with like
diapers on their heads because you know
it's blue they're called muslim okay
I'm Malcolm Gladwell Patrick Pat David
was on flagrant we might be drunk to not
have a guest Eric Griffin was a guest on
the Harland Highway Ian fight answers on
this [__] podcast taste buds battle
pencil vs pen Annie Letterman was on the
Honeydew Liza Schlesinger was on the
blocks podcast and nimish Patel was a
guest on you know what dude as far as
brand new stand-up specials are either
out right now or coming out soon Brian
holtzman's new special cancel Holtzman
is out right now on YouTube a very funny
54 minutes all filmed from the main room
of the world famous comedy store
shouldn't there be time limits on
handicap parking spaces
I hope everybody got a place to park but
you you know you want to park and the
whole thing's wide open these people
don't come out at night
we also have Jason Banks light-skinned
out now on YouTube as well as Jeremiah
Watkins new crowd work documentary that
came out earlier today and some future
stand-up specials to look forward to
Mateo Lane has a brand new special
coming out on YouTube June 11th and Matt
Rife just announced his first ever world
tour with a Joe promo video featuring
Ashton Kutcher and Mila Kunis
also Wanda
specials out now on Netflix I know last
week accidentally called her Wanda skies
I was just reading that really fast off
of this laptop I think I might be
dyslexic sorry about that Wanda if
you're excited for any of these upcoming
specials tours or the kill Tony live
show you should probably consider
joining our Discord server so you can
talk comedy with a bunch of like-minded
fans that link to the Discord is in our
bio right now along with all the other
links like the link to the second
channel to our Instagram to our Tick
Tock the joke World Universe goes deep
we're everywhere we're on everything so
get tapped into our other stuff you did
a great job with the main Channel but we
got 13 000 on Instagram 250 000 on
YouTube come on guys I'm just kidding I
don't mean to be you know greedy or
whatever thank you for watching
at joke world
and the world is wrld
[Music]
thank you